leute was sie auf jeden fall noch
loswerden muss jetzt bevor es losgeht an
die jüngeren unter euch geht jetzt nicht
davon aus oder nehmen dieses video jetzt
nicht als anreiz dazu bei möglichst
vielen gewinnspielen anzumelden weil ich
glaube es ist nicht normal oder sagen
wir mal relativ unwahrscheinlich dass
wenn ihr jetzt 30 40 50 gewinnspiele mit
macht dass wir da noch irgendwas
gewinnen also ich will auf keinen fall
dass erst mit 12 13 jahren wie auch
immer hingeht und eure ganzen adressen
daran gibt lasters bitte das meiste wenn
ich nahezu alles ist erst ab 18 oder 16
ich bin mir als unsicher
jetzt gehts los mit dem video also ganz
ganz wichtig und ich wünsche viel spaß
jetzt ist es halt noch einmal deine hand
hier vor
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich gibt es gut
wird würde ich auch wie immer eigentlich
sollte dieses video jetzt heute dann
nicht kommen weil ich wollte eigentlich
noch etwas warten nur es ist immer noch
nicht da und ich habe jetzt von vier
tagen kein video mehr gemacht weil ich
einfach weil wir hier bei meinen eltern
bin und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen hier
in meinem zimmer oder generell hier in
diesem umfeld in köln ist halt viel
leichter videos zu drehen als hier
deswegen nimmt es mir nicht übel ich
jetzt mal kurz eine kleine story und
zwar an ich würde sagen wir gucken uns
erst mal ein kurzes video an was ich
nämlich damals gesehen habe und das fand
ich eigentlich ganz lustig und zwar habe
ich vor ungefähr zwei monaten oder einem
monat ich habe keine ahnung vielleicht
ist das auch noch länger her
dieses video gesehen traumberuf gewinner
dieser mann lebt von gewinnspielen was
ich eigentlich ganz cool fand ich habe
mich auch gefragt okay vielleicht ist
das jetzt auch nicht so 100 prozent aber
ich fand es ganz interessant und ich
habe mir gedacht
wir schauen wir jetzt erstmal zusammen
rein damit es auch versteht als ich
informatik studiert habe und dann
plötzlich davon erfahren hat dass ich
eine reise nach australien geworden habe
und ich bin meinem informatikstudium
nicht so ganz zufrieden war habe ich mir
gesagt okay die muss ich jetzt auf jeden
fall machen hab alles hingeschmissen
barriere australien gegangen und wollte
das einfach weiterleben mit gewinnen
meine meine urlaube bekommen meinen
leben finanzieren
bei johannes ist fast täglich
beschreibung er hat schon über 400
gewinner abgestaubt
über hotelgutscheine bis zum
flachbildfernseher seine wohnung ist
inzwischen eher ein warenhaus und es
hört und hört nicht auf zu mal habe ich
hier paar tablets die ich gewonnen habe
die stative die auch immer schmeckt
buchgutscheine jede menge hier habe ich
jetzt zum beispiel eine für europa park
für vier erwachsene wenn wir hier vorne
eine oral b zahnbürste handys
smartphones so das ist das video
es geht halt um diesen typen der sein
leben davon finanziert bei gewinnspiel
mitzumachen und dann gewinnt und hat in
seinem leben schon über vier oder fünf
100 mal irgendwas gewonnen hat sei es
jetzt handys tablet t shirt
essensgutschein hotelgutschein was auch
immer ich fand dass auf jeden fall ganz
lustig und habe mir gedacht ich
probier's doch einfach auch mal sowas
vielleicht gewinnt man ja mal irgendwas
keine ahnung ich habe noch nie bei so
etwas mitgemacht oder noch nie was
gewonnen und ich habe mich vor ungefähr
eineinhalb monaten mal hingesetzt und
hab mich soweit 50 oder vielleicht sogar
mehr das geht ja relativ schnell ich
habe mir eine e-mail gemacht und zwar
alex gewinnt web.de ja und habe mich bei
ganz vielen gewinnspielen eingetragen
also das müssten wirklich so eigentlich
passt so an die 100 gewesen sein ich
habe mich sogar heute auch noch bei
einigen gewinnspielen eingetragen und
habe einfach mal so geschaut was es
gerade neues gibt ich habe das damals
auf jeden fall alles über diese seite
gemacht die heißt einfach sparsam de und
da ist alles möglich am gewinnspiel
abgegeben man muss dann nur seine e mail
seine adresse zum teil manchmal auch
nicht und seinen namen angeben und schon
nimmt man halt an jedem möglichen
details teilt und ja das hier zum
beispiel man könnte einen wellness
wochenende in der schweiz gewinnen
müsste sich dazu dieses video anschauen
und dann die fragen beantworten und dann
hier seinen namen angeben straßenausbau
post setzt sagen e-mail-adresse das dann
senden und schon nimmt man teil wobei
das jetzt relativ umfangreich ist und
viel zeit kostet da hätte ich jetzt
überhaupt keinen bock drauf hier zum
beispiel musste ich nur meine mail
angeben und so weiter und habe
erfolgreich schon teilgenommen
und ja dann wartet man halt einfach mal
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich fand es
wirklich extrem heftig wie viele
gewinnspiele es gibt es gibt wirklich zu
jeder scheiße gewinnspiele und da sind
zum teil auch wirklich hochwertige
sachen dabei was mir jetzt noch so im
kopf geblieben ist war irgendwie eine
woche österreich irgendwo konnte man in
sofa gewinnen
konnten 3000 euro shopping gutschein von
ikea gewinnen man konnte über rewe
irgendwie gutscheine gewinnen dann gab
es noch so exotisches gemüse smartphones
ganz klar so bücher von pflanzen gab es
auch ja ich habe wohl sogar eine pflanze
gewonnen
die ist allerdings noch nicht darauf die
wollte ich eigentlich noch warten bevor
ich das video machen und zwar habe ich
eigentlich einen bonsai baum gewonnen da
kann ich mich auch noch erinnern ich
glaube da konnte man 70 bonsai bäume
gewinnen also wenn man sich eingetragen
hat haben 70 leute die halten mitgemacht
haben den bonsai baum gewonnen gut ich
bin jetzt gerade gar nicht nur in köln
sondern bei meinen eltern und ich habe
diese adresse angeben
der bonsai baum ist allerdings immer
noch nicht angekommen ein mitbewohner
ist da und keinen fall deswegen mache
ich jetzt einfach dieses video und was
man auch sagen muss es gibt so viele
menschen die da wirklich mitmachen bei
diesem ding hier konnte man jetzt glaube
ich irgendwie eine uhr gewinnen geraune
uhr und gebt euch das mal wir
kommentieren so viele leute darunter
dass sie halt diese uhr haben wollen
also das geld wirklich unendlich weit
nach unten und ich denke mir wie viele
menschen suchen im internet nach solchen
gewinnspielen also ich glaube die chance
dass man da wirklich was abräumen so 4
500 sachen schon als ob das jetzt so
stimmt kein plan gut der grund warum ich
das video jetzt schon mache ich habe
letztens irgendwas gekriegt aber ich
habe schon mal so ein geguckt weil ich
war ja natürlich so ein bisschen
neugierig und ich konnte die sache jetzt
zu nichts zu ort und was ich wirklich
bestellt habe ich habe mir jetzt nur
gedacht dazu wenn dich wirklich das
video machen und euch auch mal zu fragen
ob ich vielleicht mich bei noch mehr
sachen anmelden soll und dann keine
ahnung einfach mal abwarten und so in
zwei monaten da noch mal so ein video
machen ob irgendwas angekommen ist da
würde ich sagen gibt auf jeden fall
jetzt mal ein deutlicher nach oben ich
wollte noch jetzt mehr vorweihnachtszeit
selber noch mal gewünscht wir machen so
wenig wie letztes jahr wenn ihr darauf
auch bock habt schreibt peschek
gewinnspiel in die kommentare
und wir checken jetzt mal das paket ab
weil ich wirklich gespannt bin und es
müsste eigentlich irgendwas sein was ich
halt dann anscheinend gewonnen habe ich
habe keine ahnung also ich super auf
eine andere kamera ist sofort das ist
das paket beim oder film das jetzt und
ja mal sehen was es sein wird ihr könnt
ja mal gerne jetzt in die kommentare
schreiben was ihr glaubt was
[Musik]
was ist das ich kann mich aber
eigentlich nur daran erinnern dass ich
bei staubsauger mitgemacht habe ich muss
allein möchten diese leute würde so laut
gewesen richtig auf die eier
vor allem bei uns vor der wohnung in
köln ist auch mal leute wir haben hier
ein laubgebläse von ikea ich würde sagen
wir gehen wir schnell nach draußen weil
hier kann ich damit ja überhaupt nichts
anfangen
und da jetzt raus weiter das ding hat
einfach den stecker
aber was bringt mir das denn wie soll
ich mit einem kabel rumlaufen draußen
wir können ja kommen wir gehen mal kurz
wir testen jetzt mal also ich möchte
sagen dass bietet sich jetzt sogar
anwalt hier ist einiges lob von den
bessern gefallen hier ist einiges laub
von den bäumen gefallen so wollte ich
sagen er ist sogar mit rollen
was für ein lauf staubsauger oder laub
staubsauger oder weil wir das loch
wegblasen tut es ja nicht ach so dann
mach dass du dich auch sehr mit dem
staubsauger weil leute ich kann mich nur
noch an erinnern ich habe bei einem
staubsauger gewinnspiel mitgemacht oder
sogar bei mehreren und so sieht zwar ist
kein staubsauger aus aber das ist ja
auch nicht schlecht damit wir besorgen
es erstmal kabel dass ich aus der kanzel
staubsauger wie einfach gewonnen
wieso hast du dich beteiligt an was für
ein spiel nur meine tante ist auf jeden
fall schon begeistert davon
jetzt wurden gestern die uhren
umgestellt und es ist schon übels
frieden könne werden gerade 17 uhr
[Applaus]
so sei der bereich führen
ich hatte noch nie in meinem leben und
dinge und ich habe so etwas noch nie
gesehen um ehrlich zu sein ich stufen
einstellen hier kann man von stufe 1 bis
leute jetzt passt genau was das kann
wie groß ist noch alles drin hier
also ich wusste bis zum heutigen tage
nicht das ist sowas gibt aber ich finds
gut man kann das hier auch alles
umstellen an den größen also wenn du
noch kein weihnachtsgeschenk hab ich
packe euch mal ein laubsauger oben in
die video beschreibung ja kann man sich
auch feststellen ich mache jetzt noch
das restliche laufwerk und was glaube
ich auch ganz cooles das wird
automatisch klein gemacht und kommt dann
hier unten in diesem beutel rein
irgendwie ist alles klein gemacht wurden
direkt also leute das war's mit dem
video
wenn ich das weiterhin auch noch mal
machen lassen noch nach oben da ist echt
kalt irgendwie ins tor ab wir sehen uns
das ja voll hier so kalt machen wir
sehen uns morgen wieder gibt es ein
neues video und ich habe jetzt noch ein
bisschen spaß hier draußen
haut rein mein bruder kann ja auch
folgen hast du noch instagram hier ist
ja die beute vergisst man halt mal deine
hand hier vor traust dich dass wir diese
blätter die werden kleinen gemachten
kann man richtig mit karacho hier raus
so gut